Ehhhhh how's it going!!!
Buh uh Breuhs
je m'appelle (my name is)
ahhhh pewdiepie
Leh Edgar
Shud ze fuck up Felix
Welcome to Passpartout- The Starving Artist
Let see how long I will do this accent
Pewdiepie plays a game! What is this?
twenty seven five
Act 0
Here we go
this is [a] game about love
drawing
and only drawing, I don't know why I added love in there
Maybe maybe there's a love in there somewhere
'click the easel to start painting'
What's an e-- oh that's an easel
I did not know that well I can draw whatever I want?
I will draw Slippy and it's perfect rendering
Is it what this game is about you just draw?
that's awesome
[intense background music]
Why do I even bother this is so shit? What the fuck is this? Oh, it's done. I guess
Wait, I can't - put it somewhere
here
here ?
I don't-- all right there. Okay can someone please buy this painting
Jeff (of course)
Hey, what up daug you want to buy my Jeff?
Please buy it
Now well shove your baguette up your ass boi
[inhale]
[disgusting burp] Yeeeees, I'll take it
I guess he like Jeff huh, I guess we just draw another one
Is this what we're going to do this video
just fucking draw? I think by the shade of this you can already tell who I'm drawing
There's only one man in the world with this beautiful skin complex and his name rhymes with rump
But I don't know okay. That's that's him there you go. Why do I even bother? We'll call him rump
Does anyone want to buy rump? Please
Might as well just call this video 'Pewdiepie draws for a fucking hour ' Jesus christ
All right, who else should we draw. I'm taking suggestions
You made a painting mate, but you didn't make it art
'Cynth'
Cynth has you seen your fucking face??
'cause you look like SHIT
there you go finally someone who knows
pleasure doing business with you B-daug
all right speaking of dogs, let's draw this shitty meme that everyone is obsessed with
and I don't understand why
Déjà vu [earrape]
I honestly was not implant-- planning to enjoy this game so much
I was like why are people playing this game? All you do is draw
What's the fucking point? Yeah idiot you're all idiots and Meanwhile here I am
Well, I'm pretty sure
that
If YouTube doesn't work out I can always become just a street artist
'cause god damn look at this piece of art. It makes me emotional
I'm having an emotional episode right now. This is so goddamn beautiful. I don't know where to begin
I did it. I did it. It's my Mona Lisa. It's my hot dog
But a hot dog hot dog everybody that's my name hotdoghotdogerrybody
there you go, and that will be saw oo you fucking whore
you best not
if you criticize
Microaggressions are those everyday comments or  used by the privileged to keep others in their place
microaggressions accumulate
FUCKYOU
I put my heart and soul into that
Literally kill yourself.
What does she want from me? What will make her satisfied? Now I know what triggered people feels like
Cuz fuck Jesus Christ, alright. See if you can guess which one I'm drawing now
This is gonna be my new Mona Lisa
Lacks energy fu--  Cynth! How about you take some cyanide, okay?
Have you thought about that see how your energy goes you fucking bitch you fucking whore
Sorry I might seem aggressive, but it frustrates me when people say they know art
Shi-- . Yes, you will have it with your baguette
take it finally someone that understands
and appreciates
Yeah it's perfe--haha
Yes, okay. Here we go. Sell it look at that shit boy. It's absolutely stunning
You fucking what mate let's sell it hopefully fucking cyanide bitch will appreciate it
I guess we just keep drawing
Steve, why don't you...
leave
He did he did leave, okay? Well, whatever
Lacks energy, I don't like--
IT'S DOING THIS HOW IS THAT NOT ENERGY FOR YOU?
Maggie, you spiked hair fucking whore
Sorry, I get too emotional about my art some say I can't take criticism
I'll draw something close to my heart then George fuck no one wants to buy it
beautiful piece of art
why does no one want my arrrt
Colors too crazy. The fuck do they want from me
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME (stop it's too close)
Literally kill yourself Maggie. I don't know why you come here to spit at my work
She's such a mean person such a mean spirited person
okay well, let's try this again
literally stop stop okay
I'm trying my best here
Wait I changed to spray, but I don't want spray. What the fuck
NOOOOOO
I clicked it away by accident
I'm gonna have to sell Ponr hub
Why is there not a regret button?
Why does my life not have a regret button, can someone answer me that?
I'm gonna have to speed up now otherwise. I'm gonna run out of fucking business. God damn it
Okay, it's done, and it's beautiful
Okay, can someone please for the love of God buy this one, or else I'm going out of baassnuzz
'Skillfully made' You bet your fucking sweet ass it's skillfully made
What us this scale mean?
Alright bid higher
Hell yeah mother fucker hell yeah
I'm the king I'm the goddamn king
this is gonna be my Mona Lisa, I know it
Sugoi desu, sudoi-- sugoi ekusu ne-- kawai desu-no
Yes, I would buy that I would definitely buy that hell yeah
xxsugoitacion [awesometation]
that one I will sell for at least a couple of dollars
this one is personal
I really hope uhhh you guys are gonna like this one
Comment comment along if you figure out what it is
two hundred? Hell yeah
Xxsugoitacion is yours, buddy
I just realize how incredibly obvious it is when I'm drawing
if I start it like this
Have you guessed what I'm drawing yet?
No?
Well try again mother fucker
BOOOOi
hell yeah, my name a Nick Crompton and my collar stay poppin
Yes, I can rap and no I'm not from Crompton
YES it's AWESOME!
I love it. He's so-- I would buy this art and I know you would too
I'd call this one England is my
City
beautiful
This one is gonna go for a lot, I can tell
'I hate pink' Well, then you hate life because if you hate on this art
Then you hate life itself this man is God this man is God himself you were born from this man
You may not know it, but you are
Fuck you George
This better be good
Shut up. What is he drawing? I don't know
This is truly beautiful. This is going to change lives
Is it Spongebob perhaps?
the answer will shock you
All right it's Michael from Vsauce.
Yeah, no fuck it I don't-- goddamn
just give me money, just give me money at this point
'Where's the energy mate it's so--'  Fuck you. Okay? Let's finish this off
Let's finish this off with a good meme , a good meme everyone.
I'm sure you all recognize this guy
But wait a minute. It is not finished yet
Now that's a logo type right there
Fine, I'll sell fucking Vsauce 'cause it's so ugly
There it is
Okay, all right. I think I think it's time for me to stop. I am clearly addicted. This is a super fun game
I really enjoy it. No one will buy my fucking Nick Crompton. I don't get it. I don't get it
What do I have to do here? What do I have to do here? Maybe change name on it?
Anyway, if you enjoyed this video, please leave a thumbs up.
Thank you guys so much for watching I'll see you tomorrow with another episode, another
'Bad col--' fU-you piece of SHIIIIT